you know the other aspect of the drag
queens that's important here is
the transgender person
wants to pretend that he's really the
woman it's a it's a realistic
performance of a woman the essence of a
drag show is that it's a very
unrealistic performance this
difference between realism and
unrealism is at the heart of it there
was a a tick tock that went viral the
other day of some confused woman
describing not just her transgenderism
but her neo pronouns and specifically
why she uses them
so neopronouns are any set of pronouns
that aren't officially recognized in the
language that you use someone might use
neopronouns because
officially recognized pronouns might
give them dysphoria or using
neos could give someone gender euphoria
i use them because they give me euphoria
because i really enjoy confusing people
with my gender identity
which sounds kind of weird but it gives
me euphoria so whatever
i really like using they them and fair
in conversation like when i'm talking
and i really like using bun bun self uh
like if i'm texting someone or
i guess just on the internet
um that's that's the way i like using
them
so an example of faith fair pronouns
could be i really like fair jacket today
it's fair favorite color
they like the color purple
and an example of bun bun self pronouns
could be
bun showed up on my 4u page today bond
really likes using neopronouns
bun really gets a kick out of this
and bun would prefer if you would refer
to bun by bun self's preferred bun buns
and pronouns that's true it does not
give me euphoria it gives me bemusement
but it doesn't give me euphoria euphoria
is the key word there i'm so glad this
gal gets it this gal i don't think she
intended to point this out but she says
the opposite of dysphoria is euphoria in
the transgender ideology dysphoria means
this
unrealistic view of your own body that
is a negative view of your own body
but euphoria as it is used in modern
life is an unrealistic feeling of
happiness euphoria is what you get when
you shoot up heroin
that's the it's the feeling that you get
you're not you're not really happy
you're not really thriving or
flourishing but it's the feeling that
you get
and
this this gal seems to suggest that
those are the only two ways to live in
this dysphoria or this euphoria how
about you live in real life how about
real life with real happiness grounded
on real things that is entirely missing
from the conversation
right now head on over to podium.com
slash
knowles from supply chain issues to
increase demand on top of everything
else that business owners have to manage
the businesses that are thriving right
now are the ones that are forward
thinking podium helps your small
business stay ahead of the curve with
modern messaging tools that make it easy
for your customers to connect with your
business it is really really easy to
fall into a rut as a business owner do
not let that happen check out podium
from healthcare providers to plumbers
over 100 000 businesses are texting with
customers through podium customers love
the convenience businesses love the
results you want an example one car
dealer sold a 50 000 truck in just four
text messages a jeweler sold a five
thousand dollar ring
and coordinated curbside pickup all
through text right now see how podium
can help to grow your business watch a
demo today at podium.com knowles that's
podium.com slash knowles podium
let's grow
the the extreme
un
the extreme unrealism of what the left
is pushing especially when we're talking
about the sex stuff is a big problem and
i feel for this girl this girl
who says you know refer to me as bun bun
self and
fairy pronouns and whatever all these
pronouns that are even beyond the 57
usual ones that we get these days
this girl is it has been raised at a
time of such surreality where life is
not lived primarily in the real world
but has lived in the virtual world it's
increasingly going to be lived in the
metaverse it's lived on social media
it's lived with a focus only on oneself
it's lived with a focus on how i feel
not with a care to other people's pain
or objective reality but only a care for
one's own
pleasure a a culture of narcissism
and so it's no surprise that she says
this gives me euphoria what a weird
thing to say she doesn't say this makes
me happy or this is a good thing to do
she says it gives me euphoria
it's like when people it's when people
describe themselves as a bag of
chemicals they say gosh i got such an
adrenaline rush
they don't say boy i was excited wow
that thrilled me no they say i got an
adrenaline rush because you're just
thinking of yourself as a big bag of
chemicals that just reacts to different
stimuli and when the stimuli poke you
and make you feel good on the inside
then you want more of that that gives
you euphoria and when they make you feel
bad you want less of that with no care
to objective reality or to discipline or
to some temporary pain that might
strengthen someone over time
something tells me that these people who
are just focused entirely on themselves
and their own
low base pleasures somebody tells me
they don't have a great relationship
with their parents
just i'm not saying it's 100 of the time
but usually when you see people dancing
around talking about bun bun self and
all you know all sorts of mutilations on
them and they're screaming and they're
yelling and they're protesting outside
of the supreme court justice's houses
you look at that you say huh
something tells me
you don't have a great relationship with
dad
it's a little harsh to say
but
999
times out of a thousand that is going to
be
the case
so this is why this is one this is a
problem that you've got to solve
first
before we figure out the debt and the
deficit before we figure out um
immigration before we figure out the tax
rates and the and the way that we can
kind of fix some of the institutions and
the energy policy before you can figure
out
higher level political issues
if you've got a country where your
family has completely broken down
you're not going to solve any of those
political problems because the family is
the basic political institution daily
wire just did an analysis of new census
data
according to this analysis there are a
lot lots of parts of this country
where most people do not grow up with
two parents
puerto rico
just kind of america kind of kind of
sort of part of america
only 38 percent of puerto rican children
live with two parents
washington dc only 48
of
dc residents
children live with two parents
mississippi louisiana new mexico
it's a little higher it's above the 50
threshold but not much 55
57 according to census data
you you can't have a flourishing country
that way that is going to create just
think about it just think about
something that happened in your
childhood whether you grew up with two
parents or one parent or no parents or
however you grew up
think about one thing that happened even
if you grew up in the greatest household
ever
leave it to beaver father knows best
donna reed household
did something happen in your childhood
that kind of messed you up a little bit
did i don't know
daddy and mommy fought a little bit too
much or
i don't know daddy traveled too much or
there was some there was some big fight
that broke out or even in your extended
family aunt so and so didn't talk to
uncle what's his face and did something
happen
when you were a kid daddy yelled at you
one time okay think about that that
relatively minor experience of childhood
trauma
and now have it be that your parents
just don't care about you and they don't
care about you enough to try to to
focus on your upbringing and daddy
disappears for for huge stretches of
time if he's there at all and or maybe
mommy doesn't really care about maybe
maybe mommy just leaves daddy
and you know she puts the kids kind of
second or third if she's thinking about
them at all and you know look they're
just going to focus on them they're
going to live their best life okay and
frankly it'll be better for the kids if
mommy and daddy are are happy quote
unquote
pursuing their own selfish desires do
you you can't
if if one incident at the dinner table
is going to kind of mess you up as a kid
no matter how
nice your upbringing was
imagine you're living in a society where
most
kids don't live with both of their
parents maybe they get to maybe they get
to see both their parents sometime i
don't maybe
think about how much that's going to
mess up all of those kids think about
how much that's going to mess up society
you know it's not not every political
issue comes down to some textbook
explanation
and some formal academic debate and
frankly more of of what shapes our
politics is that ronald reagan said
politics begins around the dinner table
what happens when there's no dinner
table what happens when mommy and daddy
just aren't home and you're sitting at
home on a snack tray alone watching tv
well then that dinner table that's going
to be your politics and especially when
the tv
that's that's being pumped into you or
the streaming now
is promoting radical woke propaganda
especially when you're the only solid
relationship that the kids have is going
to be with their teacher in a public
school there are great public school
teachers but there's a lot of crap that
goes on in the public schools too
or their only relationship is with some
movie star on tv or their only
relationship is some parasocial
relationship on social media pushing
crazy woke stuff that's a major major
political problem that's not enough to
say you do you figure it out well i'm
just going to focus on no we we need to
structure our society in such a way that
it's better for those kids for society
as a whole if we don't do that
we're just conceding the culture to the
radicals we've done that for 50 years
it's led us to this madness maybe it's
time to try a new strategy i'm so glad
you liked that clip now if you wouldn't
mind
ring that bell subscribe like get the
notifications also please head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts click subscribe and then here's
the crucial part guys
you need to click the link wherever
you're watching this or listening to
this and then you've got to email this
to your friends you have to email it
text it whatsapp at myspace you have to
do it there are still people in america
who do not have the privilege of
watching this show make sure you help to
rectify that today we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]